now you know the atheists came out and
said the atheists have to vote against
Christian nationalism as if their lives
depended on it and you know that the
edgy redditer atheists who have become
unwitting uh Satan worshippers or
putting up Idols all over state capitals
Notice Me Senpai notice me anyway
Professor Jacob has found some atheist
Reddit tier videos to uh get our get our
brains firing you said in a speech
famously that I think a case can be made
that faith is one of the world's great
evils comparable to the small poox virus
virus but harder to eradicate I do think
that yes um because um what I'm talking
about there is
Faith where faith means belief in
something without evidence because if
you believe something without evidence
then that justifies anything you you're
no longer vulnerable to somebody coming
back at you and saying hang on a minute
let me argue the case if you believe it
without evidence which is what faith is
then you don't argue the the case you
say no I'm not arguing that case this is
my faith it's mine it's private I don't
I don't descent from it I don't retreat
from it you're just going to have to
accept it now that is evil well well yes
I said that pork chops pork chops are
the slimiest most hard shelled things in
the
world by which I I mean by pork chops I
mean Lobster Tales yes if when I say
pork chops I mean Lobster tales and that
is why
my argument that they're slimy and hard
shell is so
persuasive it's true if you start with a
false premise then you can ironically
it's kind of the point that he thinks
he's making but he's actually
demonstrating his point if you start
with a false premise yeah you can end up
just about anywhere but he has a false
premise the premise that faith is
believing something without evidence
that's not what faith is Faith is the
substance of things hoped for and the
evidence of things unseen that's true F
let's take it even further theology is
Faith seeking understanding I understand
and what it means is it begins actually
from logic and then it encounters
evidence in Revelation and then it
applies the rigors of reason and logic
to both that's what it is so for
instance the existence of God can be
known with certainty from the natural
light of human Reason by the natural
light of human reason from the created
world we can we can know for a fact that
God exists
because if objects are in motion there
must be an unmoved mover at the at the
end of the line that started all the
motion because if causes have effects
then there must be at the end of the
line I suppose you'd say the beginning
of the line of all that an uncaused
cause if there is such a thing as
perfection in the world then there must
be a highest good whom we call God I God
oh my God he's God that doesn't say that
the Christian religion can be understood
by the light of natural human reason
from the created world there's there's a
role of Revelation here as well but
that's not without evidence you know the
the existence of Jesus Christ is is one
of the best evidenced things in all of
human history the spread of Christianity
is a pretty good evidence of the truth
of Christianity the fact that there were
500 I witnesses to the Resurrection the
fact that the The Life of Christ is
attested to in religious sources but but
also in non-religious sources as well
the fact that these Apostles went to all
the various ends of the Earth most of
them to their deaths for a joke for a
lie for a what is it the endurance of
the church throughout the ages the the
identification of Our Lord with the
Divine logic of the universe which is
why the whole thing makes sense that
would be evidence now who can argue with
that so yeah it's true it's true Richard
Dawkins if my aunt had she would be
my uncle but that's why we have to start
with correct premises about the very
terms that we're discussing next one
God's necessary for Morality is you said
yes okay World a a baby is thrown off a
building and God exists in that world
okay did something wrong happen yeah
great world b a baby's thrown off a
building and there's no God in that
world did something wrong happen you
throw a baby off a cliff is is wrong no
matter what okay so God yeah so God
isn't necessary for Morality then that
seems like the quickest debunk of a
point I think I've ever had on the show
are you serious man qu playing with me
man no for real don't play like that
there's no world there's no world in
which there are babies if God does not
exist there is no world in which speech
is intelligible if God does not exist
there's no world in which there are
podcasts that can be understood if God
does not exist there is no reason to
trust the reliability of our faculties
of reason that's the issue but the
reason it's wrong is because there is a
moral order if God does not exist and
the moral order was created by God who
does exist whether the atheists want him
to or not obviously that's the
[Music]
issue